My husband is on a 14 hour flight home right now,
so I decided to surprise
him by making some cinnamon rolls.
He's been asking me to make him some for so long,
so I thought now is the perfect time.
I added all of my ingredients
for my dough to my Kitchen Aid.
I made sure to incorporate everything one at a time
and slowly as well,
just so everything can be needed in properly.
Once my dough was smooth,
I pulled it off the hook and formed into ball
and let that rise for about two hours
until it doubled in size.
I obviously had to try the dough.
It was delicious.
Then I punched it down to release all the air
and rolled it into what should have been a rectangle.
Once that was rolled out,
I made my cinnamon and sugar mixture
and brushed my dough with a lot of melted butter,
sprinkled my sugar on top,
rolled all of that up,
and then cut it into equal pieces.
I put those pieces into
my baking trays to rise for another 30 to 45 minutes
until they're about double in size.
After 45 minutes,
I checked on them
and they were perfect.
So I popped them in the oven,
and while they were baking,
I made my cream cheese frosting.
And the timing couldn't have been more perfect
because lucky was walking through the door
right as I was pulling these out.
They were perfectly soft. And gooey.
And he ended up having half of that sheet pan.
So I think my surprise was a success.